alors dans cette vidéo je passe mon
examen blanc du permis de conduire dean
continue c'est quatre temps normal ça
rentre dans la cale éliminatoires juste
avant d'aller passer le vrai examen
quelques heures après le même jour mais
pas filmer parce qu'on n'a pas droit
dans la voiture il ya abdel mal comme
peu de wor nino arial pour me juger une
hormone on ne doit pas s'y produire
d'importants ok il faut que je fasse une
vidéo alors comment ça le business c'est
parti pour l'examen ses partisans vont
pas nous faire franchement moi je te
cache pas en fait si je t'ai planifié
aujourd'hui c'est que tu as le niveau et
tu sais bien saboté des champions a fait
les beaux gosses savoir moi je suis là à
la base parce que j'aimerais bien un
verre au permis alors comment ça se
passe examens blancs c'est simple là je
te met en condition réelle c'est à dire
ça va durer 25 minutes tu vas être
vraiment libre à toi même je suis plus
abdel je suis l'inspecteur du gang
conduire cet appel elle entend rôle d'un
sac déjà il vient de perdre à propos de
monsieur il vous a tutoyé monsieur si je
peux me permettre
parce qu'avant il ya un politicien un
point de courtoisie c'est vrai a choisi
au volant oui je sais que si tu deux
fois déjà je règle le rétroviseur je
vous vois vous êtes très très beau on y
va on est en mouvement honneur mouvement
grosse accélération de merde au
tu préfères à l'époque je fais là à
droite je pense en balade commence déjà
des commandes réincarner sera donc
l'intersection n'avait pas évident de
mes faut s'imposer
norman pourquoi tu invites les gens sur
des vidéos de podcasts à la maison
détente ton âge et nous qui nous amène
un truc parce que je sais qu'aucune
balle en fait je trouve pour centrer
autre bien côté gauche en bleu moi c'est
comme permettre monsieur il avait
contrôlé ses avocats ont tout objectif
manqué un peu de rythme non monsieur je
vous jure il a bien elle a regardé à
prendre l'autoroute sur la droite c'est
là que ça c'est là que j'aime moi le
tournage de la vidéo j'ai mauvais -
laval a entamé le calme et déconcentre
de ouf il pas la valeur c'est plutôt la
vidéo non c'est ça les met partout comme
façon ininterrompue table la chose comme
de passer ton père né avec une voiture
automatique
ils passent pas les vitesses
vitalaire aussi mec mais c'est ta pensée
masque on va suivre la direction cergy
pourtant un peu de sérieux et
concentration
là vous en pensez quoi la lega de
l'insertion de l'insertion et magnifique
vous étiez à lezennes pas senti la
droite et comment là franchement
je comprends ça fait des années qu
important ok il faut que je fasse une
vidéo alors comment le business à 110 ou
si on peut on roule à la vitesse
autorisée
soixante dix huit pour ça s'accélère
enfin je voudrais voiture tu peux
doubler peut-être ça le stress au
toucher nouveautés compétentes si je
double je fais un carambolage padoue pas
franchement d'où pendent et bien vous
allez assister à une gestion ouais là il
ya la ligne continue
ah merde allez continuer sur la gauche
ou plutôt on revient on vient de carte
bleue perdu le contrôle après on va
faire demi tour
lille continue c'est comme un mur ça
valait va brancher des points là tu fais
ça bon les gars ça fait quoi de me voir
conduire une voiture là sa première fois
je crois moi je suis très ému de ces
stats et premiers pas de bébé
baby norman pilotes franchement c'est
que du bonheur je suis super content le
seul truc qui me gonfle un peu c'est que
je boxe tu vas pas avoir le permis est
mauvaise live qui me s'abuser j'te jure
ça fait mr si triste mais je comprends
maintenant je me tiens là où ça se
termine malgré 20 nous on est là on
rigole et tout mais l'une en train de
faire un truc concret c'est un peu comme
d'habitude j'ai envie de dire c'est bien
rétabli et exxon le démarrage de 6,6
profil comme ça il n'a pas le droit de
le faire parce que c'est toujours contre
au filet partout à l'ajustement ouais
ouais
[Musique]
il fait alors ouais je t'ai pas ses
examinateurs la bonne conduite sigean
coup enfin un compliment tu vois et toi
quand est ce que tu te dis dans le
niveau quand est ce que j'ai vu que
j'avais le niveau
quand je pense à fait un jour je sais
pas quelle caisse je vais prendre moi
après le permis
tu vois là qu'est ce qui est juste là
avec du scotch ouais bah c'est à pattes
ont permis de soirée à celle ci non cela
appelle une voiture sans permis
tu peux me dire la chicane un peu vite
normal là vous y accéder à partir du
vôtre d'accélération tu peux le faire
tourner les gars vous avez
compris qu'il s'est permis un circuit en
face aux iles unis où ton tour j'ai fait
un démarrage dynamique même temps en
sécurité mais la t&d par la voiture
c'est le démarrage en coûte quand même
pas le faire ouais ça va je suis comme
des trucs à l'accélération
ainsi qu'au siège à la voiture tu as là
exceptionnel break c'est gérard eu ça te
laisse pas déconcentrer n'avais pas le
rythme voici à quoi bon état et un
cédez-le-passage ils sont prioritaires
l'intérieur j'ai appelé passage c'est à
cause de notre faute en fait on est un
peu comme si l'ange et le cap sur tes
épaules yamal comme c'est le diable de
ouf courtoisie au volant ça ouais mais
c'est pour l'instant tu le sens commun
ba écoute qu'il faut juste juste à focus
dans les intersections en fait faut que
tu anticipes beaucoup les giratoires
j'aimerais bien oublié le mot giratoire
j'aimerais qu'on me reese est ferme dans
men in black
mais là est ce que est ce que l'on va
sortir à gennevilliers port abrite le
droit de donner des genres lui dire là
tu es bien était pas bien non l'examen
terry va rien diallo aminata est pire
que ça à la fin il te dit rien et
regarde dans les yeux dit au revoir au
repos la bonne surprise qui pourrait lui
faire c'est ce soir il arrive ce n'est
pas une automaticité à dire que t'es pas
bien c'est une moto poleman depuis tout
à l'heure mais vas-y mais posez une
question de l'asile à voir s'il doit
s'arrêter au passage piéton à 40 km
heure il lui faut quand même distance
d'arrêt alors km/heure questions que moi
je les déteste c'est une question pour
sherlock holmes 18 mètres n'est pas loin
bon là tu as une deuxième chose pour
l'intersection est bien là nos trois
voix se transforme en devoirs et on
arrive sur un giratoire à sens unique
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
donc là je je vais faire comme ça pour
montrer que je vais à droite et je
contrôle malcolm je te regarde américain
et là je prends un peu de puissance et
c'est là que lorsqu'on est en zone
à maxime ipad réjouir du bonheur des
autres malcom c'est un gros fan de
voiture et l'a même fait des vidéos
youtube des voitures la delorean donc
une 2 real comme ça fait plaisir
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que norman
situaton permis je te choisis ta caisse
oui les gars c'est quoi vos voitures bon
moi j'ai alors un évoque ta range rover
toi parce qu'on vous dit tout bon toi
comment tu te sens bien physiquement ça
va
ouais j'aurais peur tu es tout à l'heure
à l'examen il ya des trucs trop jaloux
qui arrive c'est une voix bizarre moi
c'est pas pour dire mais je sens que
j'ai depuis qu'on a commencé battu connu
mieux en mieux quoi ça en fait il est
plus détendu tout à l'heure et où tu vas
t'en c'est dommage que ce sera dur que
votre cinq minutes sinon si vous passez
à 2,24 concept chaud bonjour vomissent
d'autres actes et cette voix là c'est
bien parce que j'étais attendait au
tournant là j'allais voir si tu as well
réactif ou quoi il a fait quoi
en fait j'ai fait mouche tu vas
comprendre c'est vraiment de la conduite
c'est in fine en fait je l'aï leur
réponse à la baisse si tu passe ton
permis de conduire avec une zone et a le
droit de conduire des vraies voitures
aller dans une bombe pour faire un
créneau au nom même temps les preuves
c'est pas le place à 6 ans richard
montant bon faut que tu gères ça je te
fais confiance
ouais musique solennelle s'il vous plaît
c'est le moment où je fais le créneau
ah ça bip
stop motion
attali s'est déjà souvent arrivé j'ai
peur
tous
attendez je suis bien la coacher et
rambo tu vois quand on dépasse pas donc
c'est vrai on n'est pas trop mal mais
prochain tout tu peux on va vérifier si
je suis bien gareil c'est quasiment
vague ya rien qui est centrée tout est
vraiment comme ça quoi j'ai laissé le
truc comme ça tu pouvais pas faire mieux
il n'y a pas de place là y'a rien y'a un
mètre cinquante à un comme ça non mais
l'essentiel c'est qu'il dépend pas tant
mais c'est bien sûr ne mordent pas
certain mais j'ai reçu que j'ai
vachement jugé la fête fait des
manoeuvres on va juger quand j'ai la
manoeuvre il a trop peu mal comme là je
fais confiance je laisse faire tout seul
je monte avec remerciements il est
capable de se battre a claqué sa il a
déjà fait deux fois à tank et un
éthylotest un vrai mec dans ma tête sans
y sera je pense est parfait le choeur
kia c'était horrible à résister
la limite pour être cher avance
tellement mal ça commençait le mot
malcolm éliminés
le mec il crève un pneu donc ça commence
très très mal non c'est mort en malcolm
x et pire que moi a tant qu espace fermé
band of joy cm qu'elle termine par
l'économie mal comme la bomba super tu
vas te garer juste là c'était fini
l'examen est terminée sans que ça coûte
déjà convoqué tu vas me dire ce que tu
en as pensé réduit qu'à bon normal
comment tu te sens là il coûte je sais
pas ce qu'il a en même temps y avait des
copains derrière sa part temps de parler
maintenant des conditions pas du tout
normal voilà la main mais franchement
j'ai plutôt bien roulé une football je
sais que c'est une très bonne excuse je
sais que j'ai fait une connerie ou deux
quand même une ou deux seulement à à
nancy c'est vrai c'était à peu près ça
tu en as fait 2-3 voilà il ya eu la
ligne continue et le giratoire il
continue dans l'échangé pas commencer à
chercher des excuses mais j'avoue on
parlait pas mal au moment de la ligne
continue j'ai carrément jetée du coup là
si je devais être notés par rapport à
l'installation des ja est ce que je te
mets tous les ponts à la ceinture était
pas mal wen qui la ceinture et tout ça
fait claque
ouais c'est quand même la base d'une
ceinture réglage parfait alors je
manquais et à tous les prix au niveau
des réglages
ensuite la manoeuvre a été comment la
manoeuvre était pas très esthétique mais
à rentrer dans les clous quand même je
n'ai pas la circulation était en plein
dans la place c'est parfait c'était un
peu mieux que malcolm moi qui me suis
garé là arrêter avec vos montages
synthèse de l'assertion autoroutes ça là
où je te retire des points là pour le
coup à travers la réglementation
appliquer la réglementation ligne
continue c'est la pointe au père
activement l'allaitement là en temps
normal ça rentre dans la case
éliminatoires je te rassure tu as fait
l'erreur là je pense pas que tu vas
faire là dans deux heures tival à faire
ses choix
c'est vrai que ça arrive souvent
ça arrive souvent les élèves l'avaient
de l'examen ou juste avant l'examen ils
font des tas d'erreurs la vente a
justement de l'examen blanc et là tu
t'es show fait un petit peu tu pars
odeurs ouais mais bon je suis pas sûr de
ce genre de conseils ce que je te dirai
moi je te conseillerai proche tétouan
regard un peu plus d'anticiper au
maximum dont il faut que je garde la
confiance c'est ça le plus important
ouais mec t'as pas franchement ça m'a
fait du bien de faire un petit examen
blanc avant de terminer moi je suis un
peu échauffés jeudi
en tout cas je te fais un gros chèque et
acheter remercie pour toutes aux écoles
s'appelle excellence coin vite ça il
faut absolument suivre sur un stage vous
met un gros lien allez tous en masse
vous abonner à ce constat et par les 18e
et que c'est lorsqu'on lui parlait des
huitièmes les enfants à prendre du temps
de parole ce machin c'est par contre
j'ai pas ont permis à le dire à tout
casser et de la bombe ce mec bon allez
dans le métro les amis du coup on n'a
pas filmé mais là j'ai passé mon examen
du permis de conduire pour de vrai
l'officiel et donc j'aurai l'air et cela
dans deux jours donc rendez-vous dans
deux jours pour le vrai verdict si je le
permis ou pas a tout de suite
[Musique]
sarthois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m